hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd skin care nerd and fan of gadgets
i've had a lot of people ask me
to talk about microcurrent devices
you've probably seen these on social media
they're these little electronic devices handheld
that have two metal balls on them foreo have
launched a couple of microcurrent devices the
bear and the bear mini they've partnered with
me to do a video on how microcurrent works
i'm going to talk about the science behind how
microcurrent works how to use the device how
it feels on your skin and what results i've
gotten i've been using it every night for
three and a half weeks on just this side of my
face so i'm feeling pretty asymmetric right now
if you like nerding out about the science
behind beauty products click the like the
subscribe and click the nerdification
bell so you don't miss any videos
so firstly what is microcurrent microcurrent
is basically a really weak flow of electricity
generally it's so weak that you won't be able to
feel it or you'll barely be able to feel it there
are a couple of types of microcurrent device on
the market i've talked about the iontophoresis
devices before this is where the current goes
from the device through your face and then down
your body and back along your arm to complete
the circuit this type of device is mostly for
pushing skin care into your skin the microcurrent
devices i'm talking about today have both of the
electrodes on your face and so it completes the
circuit through a very short portion of your skin
these devices have currents in the 10 to 500
microamp range so for reference one milliamp
or 1000 microamps is how much you need to be
able to feel it that's the detection threshold
with 10 milliamps or 10 000 microamps that
will give you a painful electric shock
so how does microcurrent work this is actually
a pretty complicated question there are a lot of
benefits that microcurrent devices claim to have
these ones are the most common ones it tightens
and smooths your skin it tones contours and
lifts your face you get more defined cheekbones
and jawline it boosts collagen and elastin it
reduces fine lines and wrinkles boosts circulation
increases cellular activity and decreases
puffiness the biggest problem is that there
aren't many direct studies on humans using these
microcurrent devices that you get on the market
to firstly back up the claims but also to give us
a better idea of how they actually work so let's
talk about the background behind what microcurrent
could potentially do so we can understand what to
realistically expect and demystify some of
the jargon behind these microcurrent devices
a lot of things in your body run on electricity
and what electricity really is is a flow of
charged particles in a metal wire you have lots
of negatively charged electrons and these can
move along to create an electric current in your
body you don't have a lot of free electrons but
you do have a lot of charged ions and these
can move along and create an electric current
you might have heard of electrolytes in sports
drinks those contain a lot of the ions that
your body uses for electricity obviously
since our bodies aren't zapping around
everywhere interfering with our electronics
bioelectricity is at a pretty low level it's
in the micro amp level and that's what's in
microcurrent so how does microcurrent work
the most obvious thing that microcurrent devices
do is increase the size of your muscles this
effect is pretty much immediate and if you keep on
using it the effect becomes longer lasting and so
that's why you might have heard that microcurrent
devices are like a workout for your face
your face muscles getting buff and swole explains
a lot of the effects that people see from using
microcurrent devices as you get older your muscles
start to shrink and that's what contributes to the
saggy look the loss of plumpness and the loose
skin that we associate with older faces with
microcurrent your muscles get bigger and so you
end up with a younger look because the muscle's
bigger it stretches out the skin and so that ticks
off our tightened skin and reduces fine lines and
wrinkles because the muscle is firmer and bigger
it tones contours and lifts your face plus you
get more defined cheekbones and jawline but why
exactly does microcurrent make your muscles get
bigger and how long lasting should we expect this
effect to be this is where it gets sort of murky
and the science gets a bit vague one possible
explanation is that the microcurrent is strength
training your muscles like you're exercising them
your body uses electricity for a lot of things and
the most obvious one is sending signals through
your nerves it's electrical impulses from your
nerves that make your muscles contract and that's
how your body moves when you exercise a muscle you
put it under strain and this strain signals to the
body through a combination of tension microscopic
damage and metabolic stress that it needs to
produce more protein more muscle to deal with
this extra work but it takes about a week between
exercise for your muscles to start actually
growing but the effect of microcurrent is pretty
immediate so this immediate effect is something
that happens in strength training as well it's
often called a pump and this is when your muscles
get temporarily super super swole right after
you work out because it's getting swollen up from
extra water and extra blood this also increases
tension and this can signal again to the body
that it needs to produce more muscle normally
when it comes to muscle growth with electrical
stimulation though it's most effective when the
muscle actually contracts properly this is the
basis of ems or electrical muscle stimulation
which are those electric shock machines that you
might have seen on some late night infomercial
and microcurrent isn't like that your muscles
shouldn't be visibly contracting so it doesn't
seem like this would completely explain how
microcurrent works the other common explanation
for how a microcurrent could potentially work
is by increasing atp production you might have
heard that the mitochondria is the powerhouse
of the cell that's because it produces atp atp or
adenosine triphosphate is one of the main chemical
sources of energy in your body mitochondria make
atp from nutrients that you get from food and atp
is used to fuel lots of biological processes in
your body so things like production of protein
moving ions around and muscle contractions one
of the things that tends to happen as you get
older is that your mitochondria function less
effectively and so you produce less atp and
this also happens if you use your muscles less
now the production of atp requires a flow of
ions so an electric current and that's where our
microcurrent comes in and so it turns out that
supplying a small current from the outside so
10 to 1000 microamps for two hours on rat skin
could actually increase atp production by up to
500 percent this is the origin of the claim that
microcurrent devices can recharge your cells or
provide cellular energy the production of proteins
is affected as well electrical differences across
membranes affects how amino acids are moved around
amino acids are the building blocks of proteins
so in the same study currents between 100 and
750 microamps increased the transport of amino
acids into cells and so both of these effects
can contribute to protein production and muscle
growth interestingly in this study when they use
1 000 microamps or one milliamp which you might
remember is the smallest amount that you can feel
there's actually decreased protein synthesis
and so more isn't actually better when it
comes to electricity the flow of ions can also
change how water moves around inside your muscle
and so that could explain the immediate plumping
effect so the problem is that there isn't much
evidence that what happens in these samples of rat
skin also happens on your face even though it's
quite plausible and there's some evidence from
animal and human studies that microcurrents can
increase muscle growth so it's probably a
combination of the strength training effects
and the atp production effects and probably some
other things as well that lead to these muscle
increase benefits of microcurrent now
with the other claims the fact that
you're massaging your face with these devices
could explain some of the other things like
boosting circulation and decreasing puffiness
with the collagen and elastin increase effects
the theory is that since you have more atp and
atp is used for everything including collagen and
elastin production then having more of it around
will lead to increases in collagen and elastin
so is microcurrent worth it all in
all microcurrent has a really dramatic
immediate effect and potentially some
longer-term anti-aging benefits as well
but those longer term effects aren't really well
tested and so there's no guarantee that they'll
actually happen but i think there are still some
really big things going for microcurrent the
biggest advantage is that it targets stuff that
you can't actually reach with skin care products
to deal with changes in your face based on
muscles you'd normally need to go to botox
fillers and surgery so when we're looking at
the cost and the time investment we shouldn't
be comparing microcurrent devices to skin care
products we should be comparing them to botox
fillers and surgery and when we make that
comparison microcurrent isn't actually that
expensive there's also a small time investment and
minimal side effects at the very least there's a
short-term lifted appearance that only takes about
two or three minutes to make and that lasts for
a decent amount of time so half a day or full
day that's enough to make a difference to your
appearance that would be really hard to achieve
otherwise and so if you compare that to putting
on makeup daily then it's not a huge time
investment the potential long-term effects
would be a really great bonus but i think even
if you only believe in the immediate effects
it can be worth it especially if your face is
starting to droop a bit and of course if you'll
actually end up using the device the really
good thing is that you can quickly see what
the effects will be like and whether or not
you like them so after the first time you use
it you'll get a good preview of what to expect
and so it's not like a lot of skin care products
where you have to wait for weeks or months to
see if that investment is actually worth it
one other popular non-invasive way of getting
bigger face muscles is facial yoga this is
where you do a whole bunch of face exercises
to like schwarzenegger up your face and i think
microcurrent has a few advantages over this first
it's less time consuming you're only meant to use
microcurrent devices for less than five minutes
a day whereas facial exercises you're meant to do
for 30 minutes or so there's also the fact that
you often can't purposely exercise the muscles
that you want to exercise we tend to get trained
into unconscious patterns of what muscles we like
to use and it's really hard to untrain that if
you've ever been to a physiotherapist you know
that a lot of it is desperately trying to clench
muscles that you haven't been clenching right
your whole life if you do the facial exercises
correctly then you should be targeting the right
muscles and not over exercising the ones that are
already really swole but with microcurrent it's a
lot easier just to shove the device on there and
target the correct muscle facial exercises also
make you contort your face a lot and unfortunately
repetitive facial movements is how we etch a
wrinkle into our skin that's why a lot of wrinkles
are called expression lines so this is things like
crow's feet from smiling marionette lines and
smokers lines from pursing lips it's a bit like
how you end up with the most wrinkles on a leather
wallet in the places that you bend the most so
facial exercises could be deepening your wrinkles
while it's plumping up your face with microcurrent
your face doesn't actually move and so that's
not an issue the downside with microphone is
that you actually have to go and buy a device and
it's a bit harder to use it while you're driving
so onto at-home devices there are quite a
few on the market and obviously they're a
bit weaker than the in-clinic versions and so it's
recommended that you use these close to every day
this is the foreo bear and this is the foreo bear
mini they are both pretty small and portable the
bear is a bit larger and so that's meant for all
over face treatment whereas the mini is smaller
it's meant for more targeted treatment like
around your lips both of these have spherical
electrodes and a silicone body and so you
can actually wash these with soap and water
as well as the microcurrent both of these have
foreo's t-sonic pulsations which you might already
know from luna and ufo these are meant to massage
your face and help your products absorb better
you can adjust the intensity of the microcurrent
so this has five levels this has three and you
can turn the t-sonic pulsations on and off the
bear has a special safety feature which is the
anti-shock system this scans your skin resistance
a hundred times per second and it adjusts the
current to suit it in 0.002 seconds so this
guarantees a shock-free treatment which is good
if you're a bit scared of microcurrent devices
it doesn't make it any less powerful though the
bear is actually more powerful than a lot of other
microcurrent devices on the market it operates at
a higher frequency with 50 pulses per second i've
been using the bear on just the right side of my
face every night for the last three weeks and i'm
actually really happy i'm making this video now
because i can finally even my face up again to
me the results are pretty dramatic but i think
that's because i know my face and i can feel my
face i think to everyone else it's pretty subtle
so firstly when i smile it feels a lot tighter on
my right side so it's a little bit like how after
you've exercised for a while and your muscles
have gotten toned you feel like they're a lot more
firmer and more in control when i poke my
cheeks the right side also feels a bit firmer
if i tilt my head forwards the nasolabial fold
here is also a bit less deep i also try to use
this headband to apply equal pressure
on both sides but i think the problem
is it's never quite in exactly the right spot
and so it's really hard to see the comparison
so i thought i'd use the bear on my left side
which hasn't had a microcurrent treatment for
a few months and then i'll talk through how to use
it how it feels and then we can see if we can see
a difference so you want to start with a clean
dry face so that the current isn't interrupted
when it flows through the device and through
your skin when it's flowing correctly then you
shouldn't be able to feel much on your face maybe
it'll feel a little bit firmer but that's about it
now electricity likes to take the path of least
resistance and so that means through the more
watery areas of your face like the deeper skin
tissues and the muscle but the dead skin on the
surface of your face is quite dry and so you want
to wet that and that's why you need to use a gel
most microcurrent brands have their own gel
so foreo has serum serum serum which is a
really nice hyaluronic acid serum you can
also use aloe vera gel or ultrasound gel
the problem i found with every jello tried is
that if you put it all over your face at the start
then it dries out by the time you get to other
parts of your face and if it does dry out then
it doesn't conduct properly and it can start
giving this little prickly feeling so i find
it easiest to apply the gel to one area only and
treat it and then move on to the next spot the
prickling feeling isn't really painful it's a bit
uncomfortable it feels a bit like being snapped
with a tiny tiny rubber band it tends to happen
when you don't have enough gel or if you're moving
over like a hair which is interfering with how
well that electrode makes contact with your skin
you need to download the foreo app to activate the
devices and then you can either follow the routine
in the app or you can just adjust it yourself with
the button right now there's only one routine in
the app but there are more coming i'd recommend
using the routine in the app the first couple of
times and the bear will adjust the intensities for
you automatically but it's honestly pretty easy to
use and so i usually just use it with the button
i usually watch another video on youtube while i
do it and i keep an eye on the timestamp so i
can keep track of how long i've been using it
this does also turn off automatically after
three minutes i start with applying the gel
and then you turn on the bear with by
just pressing the button so the number of
that buzzing noise is the t-sonic pulsations
i'm going to turn that off for now and so you
double click it really fast the lights here tell
you how intense the microcurrent is so right now
it is going at three even though it's not making
any noise if you want to adjust the intensity you
just press the button quickly once and it will
increase it will cycle through all five levels
so you're meant to lightly press the spheres onto
your face and both of them should be touching
and you just glide it up so i can't actually
feel anything even though i am on the second
intensity and this half of my face has never well
hasn't really had microcurrent for like months
so when the two spheres are touching your face you
can actually see the middle light turn off to show
that you're doing it properly and so if that light
stays on it means it the current's not running
so to turn it off you just hold down the
button for a few seconds so you glide it
upwards wherever you're using it on your face
avoid the eye area and the middle of your neck
and yeah it's pretty straightforward one thing
i really appreciate about these foreo devices
is that you don't have to recharge them a lot so
i've been using the bear on a single charge for
the whole three and a bit weeks now it says you
can use it for 90 uses per charge and charging it
takes 90 minutes when you do charge it it's really
nice and simple as well you just plug it into a
usb cable there there's no awkward bulky cradle or
anything so smelling already feels a bit tighter
i can feel the muscles here um activating
more than before it turns out it's stupidly
hard to smile the exact same amount at the
exact same angle for comparison and i only
did three minutes on a lower setting but
hopefully you can see some differences the
cheek is a bit more defined the jawline is
sharper and more symmetrical it's a bit hard
to tell but i was having trouble smiling evenly
before because the two sides felt so different
but after doing my left side as well it feels a
lot more natural i don't think my mouth is really
symmetrical at the best of times but comparing
me talking before and after you can see how
it's evened out now i'm really awkward about how
i've been walking around for weeks super lopsided
instead of regular lopsided so that's microcurrent
have you tried it what did you think do you have
any tips for getting the best results out of your
microcurrent device leave them in the comments
as always i hope you liked this video if you
did you can click the like and the subscribe
you can also follow me on instagram and check out
my blog lab muffin beauty science for more on the
science behind beauty products thanks to foreo
for sponsoring this probably unexpectedly deep
dive into microcurrent devices and i
will see you next time to nerd out more